we'd only been on patrol with the police
for a few minutes and we were turning
around already
the shell was in the distance but close
enough
and so it was back to their makeshift
base a location they don't want us to
reveal
the second impact seemed closer
it's a daily threat here in crematorsk
it's from the bomb shelter that they
deal with multiple challenges these
officers were the first responders to
the attack at the train station here
just over a week ago more than 50 people
most women and children died
but it's more than just russian shells
they look for saboteurs who are in this
town and sending images of potential
targets to the russians on the other
side
we've been in here for about 15 minutes
but the the police have said we've got
the all clear now so um we can head on
back with their patrol
lieutenant colonel sasha malice is just
29 and he's in charge of the patrols
here and in the neighboring town
this apartment block was destroyed in
one of the attacks a bomb or a missile
from a plane he told us do you know how
many people died
did anyone die here
the train station is in the center of
this place where now only half the
population remain the rest have left the
station is not the evacuation point
anymore though not since the mayhem here
there are moments to be thankful for
though this kindergarten was hit but the
children were not inside the attack on
the train station down the road rightly
caught the world's attention but what's
clear driving around this town is that
it was just one of so many attacks all
around is the devastation of a daily
russian bombardment
and of course with every building hit so
many more around are damaged
probably repairable but who knows when
on the road out of cremators signs of
the battle beyond broken vehicles towed
back
fuel tankers heading forward
the city of slovyansk is a symbolic
prize for russia it was the first place
the russians captured in the 2014 war
this time it's proving harder
most of those who live here have now
left but some remain and outside the
shuttered supermarket we met the flower
sellers of slaviansk russia ukraine
stupid
then for the fifth time since sunrise
the sirens sounded again
it forced our meeting with the mayor
down into the shelter
is and 60 miles away pikrovsk is the
only place in the region from where
people can now get a train out
and on platform one the cruelty of this
war
the price of one man's war mark stone
sky news in eastern ukraine